hey guys
welcome back to the anime culture corner
so the first episode of attack on titan
season 4 is out and you can already tell
that it's gonna be a wild ride
did anyone else feel like the episode
was just super short
maybe it's just from the hype we've been
waiting and anticipating this for so
long that the 20-minute episode
length felt like seconds and so clearly
we've shifted our focus for now to the
marlins specifically the titan shifters
along with the death of irwin in season
3 and the passing of the colossal titan
armin
we're seeing the end of the previous
generation of titan shifters
there's colt who's the chosen successor
to zeke's beast titan
and gabby falco and these other two who
are potential candidates to become the
armored
the jaw titan has also been passed on
from yumir to a felony galliard and his
new design frankly looks awesome
a lot better than what ymir had an
important theme of season 4 is the
legacy that they leave for the next
generation
and how history will be remembered so
these new characters will certainly
become big players moving forward
the episode's got some really solid
action scenes and an introduction to
many
of the new characters of this season
gabby is an ambitious headstrong girl
who has a strong drive to fight the
demons from paradise island
falco is more heartfelt cares for human
life and is quick to act on this
as we saw when he tried to save gabby
colt is just trying to make a name for
himself as the new beast titan
despite the discrimination he still
faces as an eldian and marley
but before we get any further if you
like attack on titan i'm going to be
posting a bunch of videos about it and
weekly episode reviews so make sure to
subscribe
or if you like anime or manga in general
i'd appreciate the support from our
growing channel
enjoy the video something i liked a lot
in this episode is that it made us root
for these guys
like zeke and reiner even though they
are the antagonists
this episode had me hyping up reiner
absolutely destroying this fort and
massacring these people
and seeing zeke manipulate aldians and
to be going mindless titans
it was pretty cool but something that
was equally important and i'm glad they
focused on it as well was
demonstrating the cruelty of the
marlene's treatment of eldians
aldians are sent out as basically cannon
fodder on the battlefield and on the
front lines
and despite how cool it was to see zeke
change those hundreds of aldens into
mindless titans
it still shows how cruel and cold their
treatment of the aliens the demons is
they're just sending them to their death
easing them like objects i mean look at
the fear on their faces
they're not different from servants
slaves who are being punished for crimes
that their ancestors committed
i thought it was interesting how even
the potential armor titan recruits were
being sent to the front lines
they're still thought of as expendable
they're people that the marlins feel
that they can easily replace
no matter what and because of this i'd
like that the enemy isn't super black
and white anymore
i'm starting to like these titan
shifters like galliard and reiner
and i think that'll make the plot so
much more interesting and dynamic as we
move forward and see them clash
inevitably with the islanders there is
also more cg integrated into the
animation
which i thought was done extremely well
similar to anime like fate zero the cg
used for the titans blended really well
with the normal animated backgrounds
because trust me if you've seen a cg
anime before then you know just how bad
it can be
the action in this episode was still
cool as ever and mapa clearly has the
animation for this season under control
is very tasteful kudos an important plot
note however
is that somehow falco had a vision when
he was knocked out what he described
here
seems to be memories of his scout within
the walls but how
he doesn't have a titan yet and so he
shouldn't have access to memories of a
previous holder
i really can't imagine any other way of
seeing past memories
perhaps it's foreshadowing that maybe he
will end up with the armor titan over
gabby
after all reiner was once a scout
slicing titan's open on paradise island
i'm really not sure how he sees the
memories now though before he even has
the titan
it seems like gaby is the best and most
ambitious candidate for the armored
titan
but this makes me think that falco might
have more of a chance now
it's something that we should definitely
keep in mind as we follow falco's story
and i bet you're all wondering or
theorizing or looking up
who's the person in the last scene my
thoughts
i mean it could be a new character but
it's definitely not
i'm pretty confident it's gene look at
that hair and compare it to what we've
seen in the trailer
i think that somehow the people of the
island have already infiltrated marley
considering what we saw in the trailer
we know that they do have to get to
marley and fight at some point
i'm just surprised to see that they're
already there after all at the end of
season 3 they didn't have any boats or
any kind of transport that would get
them across the ocean
and we don't know the reason for being
here yet either but considering aaron's
end goal
and what he's planning i have a feeling
it's not good for the marlians
so this means we could see a huge
surprise attack of some kind if they
remain incognito and marley
or maybe jeans are just taking a
vacation on his own unlikely though
what'd you think of the episode any
gripes complaints i was a big fan
if you couldn't tell already as always
this has been the anime culture corner i
hope you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
more attack on titan content
in-depth show manga and character
analyses